we were very very close yeah
I worked very closely with his mental
health Team martial Riggs brother Sean
was a musician and he had schizophrenia
in 2008 he was arrested after kicking
out at passers-by he was held in the
prone position for more than seven
minutes and died of a heart attack
what should have happened is they should
have linked all the 999 calls and taken
to a hospital where he would have
received the medical emergency that he
needed instead he received a death
sentence because they drove him at speed
in a back of a police vehicle in a cage
to Brixton police station five police
officers were eventually cleared of
misconduct in 2019. Sean Riggs death
inside this police station is one of
those highlighted in a new report by the
charity inquest it found that black
people are seven times more likely than
white people to die after being
restrained by the police
the charity says police data has only
shown deaths in police custody when a
person is actually under arrest or in a
cell
so deaths like Dalian Atkinson's weren't
counted in 2016 police were called after
the former professional footballer was
seen behaving erratically they tasered
him for 33 seconds then kicked him in
the head one officer was jailed for
eight years for manslaughter
deaths are very much at the sharp end of
a Continuum of racist and discriminatory
policing that we've seen in official
reports in home office data from stop
and search to use of force and use of
tasers just as an example when Nusrat
metab quit London's Metropolitan Police
three years ago she was the Force's most
senior woman from an ethnic minority she
says a racist culture is behind the
disturbing statistics of black people
dying after contact with the police they
have to acknowledge that racism may play
a part and really investigate it rather
than dismiss it and that comes with more
training of understanding what racism is
it seems that that's the blockage it's a
barrier but that barium blockage and
lack of training and understanding is
then leading to lives being lost on the
street in such a tragic way the UK home
office issued a statement saying we
expect police to take a zero tolerance
approach to racism within their
workplace adding that any use of force
by police police must be lawful
proportionate and necessary critics say
only tougher punishments can make that a
reality Nadeem Barber Al Jazeera London